it is but a tent open to the weather yet
for those stricken by cholera this is
sanctuary
infants adults cholera is not fussy and
it kills when it comes quickly Colorado
is always an emergency
um the disease is extremely contagious
especially when it gets in crowded City
like here in Port-au-Prince cholera
caught early is easily treatable but
this is Haiti where nothing is simple
feni Dover watches lovingly over her son
Mickelson Regis
compared to the way he was he's getting
better because of the nurses and doctors
if it wasn't for them I probably would
have lost my baby
has more than one reason to keep
Mickelson close her son will grow up
without a father after Fanny's husband
was shot dead by gang members a routine
occurrence in Porter Prince
I don't have anybody to help me so most
likely I'll be on the street that's what
the gangs wanted for me to be out on the
street
gangs are also stopping cholera patients
from leaving their territory to get
Urgent Care Haiti has a recent painful
experience with cholera an outbreak here
in 2010 took the lives of some 10 000
people now that outbreak was later
traced back to the activities of United
Nations peacekeepers the U.N apologized
in 2016 but has yet to accept any legal
responsibility Harvard human rights
lawyer Beatrice Lindstrom advocates for
the victims Who Remain uncompensated by
the UN and I think that that has had
devastating effects for Haiti because
it's meant that the U.S commitment to
actually write its wrongs in Haiti has
been dependent on voluntary
contributions has been it's mounted to a
charitable effort that has gone largely
unfunded more than 3 million people have
no access to clean drinking water
Nicholson is recovering but the future
is tenuous
I have no help nobody
love but also great hurt in the time of
gangs and cholera through the one Al
Jazeera Porto Prince